hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and will be your driver on this
journey
um today uh i just explained to our
in-person audience we're doing something
a little bit
unorthodox rather than a normal lecture
style thing uh we're going to be playing
a training game against julian who is at
the front desk right now uh willingly
fighting me and the rest of the class in
in this game
so the way this is going to work is
pretty much in every turn we're going to
stop take some time talk about our
options and see if we can come up with
with the best moves together see if we
can understand what's going on in the
position
so here we are it's move one
any suggestions
all right d4 i love it all right we're
looking out because i play that move
here we go
uh
harrison says king e2 uh not yet not
legal yet not legal yet but maybe
okay and now it's on julian who
hopefully sees that we made a move okay
he goes knight f6
so of course you know knight f6 controls
e4
we still have to decide what opening we
want to play so let's throw out some
options we can go knight f3 go c4 and go
g3 all very normal
uh we could also even play the london
but let's not
uh so what do you guys play what do you
what do you want to play
don't ask me i'm like 1300 and i play
with london so don't ask me you play the
london oh my god all right we can try to
london we're gonna try to london so what
move do you normally use to get into
london um
okay we'll try that one
um so i think that the latest
on this bishop f4 move
is that maybe it's a little bit better
to start with knight f3 sometimes but
here maybe it doesn't matter um so d5 so
we're playing the london so what are the
london moves
yeah knight f3 e3
bishop develop all in some order so
we'll go with knight f3 first always
good to develop the pieces
i go c5 attacking our pawn
so now what
yes
that's close to mine there right away
yeah i think you can go e3 or c3 um i'm
gonna play this move uh e3 here so do
you know what move is uh sort of gonna
be
uh the biggest problem for us to deal
with here with with black setup of c5
let's let's start trying to anticipate
what what our opponent is up to uh what
could his idea be with this move c5 and
what is his next move probably going to
be to put on some pressure
okay so maybe c4 uh any other ideas so
what's going on
well i was thinking it was fun
yeah so i think that the idea was c5
more so than just gaining space with
something like c4 is is going to be to
pressure our center
and it also actually opens up a way of
playing for black directly targeted
against our early bishop development so
i think that that might be sort of the
the ideas that he's going for here and
that oftentimes revolves around this
move queen b6 now how how are queen v6
and bishop f4 related well by leaving in
the queen side our dark squares over
here are going to be a little bit weak
especially if we block off our bishop
with e3 queen b6 challenges the center
even further and also of course targets
are our pawn on b2
so now that might not necessarily change
our move here but now we sort of have an
idea of what what black is is up to yeah
the chat also says knight c6 and knight
h5 are common ideas as well all things
to look out for but i like your move e3
so we'll stick with that but we just
just want to be aware of what's coming
up make sure we're not missing anything
okay so he goes knight c6 right away
so targeting our pawns some more
so keeping these moves in mind queen b6
knight h5
how should we continue do we want to do
something over here do we just want to
continue developing
and i'll play c3
open up for the queen in case of
um
[Music]
um
you could consider it i'm actually not
up to date on my london move order
trickery but uh i think probably c4 is
is not going to be quite right here uh
because
due to the way we've played in the
london move order black is actually uh
the one with the most pressure on the
center right now and so we're not really
prepared to open things up in the middle
uh because black already has this sort
of lead in in the fight there
um so i like c3 but what what other
moves might we
uh suggest here
maybe
or
yeah knight pd2
yeah or bishop
bishop d3
yeah all all seem like normal moves so
uh there is a london expert in the chat
it looks like and he's pointing out a
line
that is useful to know if c3 queen b6
uh queen b3 then there's this annoying
line with uh c4
uh
now it's not really normal for black to
give up the pressure on the center but
in this case there's tactical
justification uh when we move our queen
back there is this bishop f5 move
attacking our queen
and so if you're not following we're
saying c3 queen b6 queen b3 c4 queen c2
bishop f5 now that bishop is hanging so
you can take it but then black takes on
b2 and our rook is sort of trapped so
we're going to avoid that line by
developing our pieces here now
that one is uh sort of a difficult one
to find over the board so it's useful
just to have that that knowledge there
so we will just develop our pieces pass
the move back to julian let him decide
how he wants to continue
just e6
okay
so what's next on our agenda
well this solid thing to do with just
during debate about that
yep i totally agree uh so we could bring
this bishop out
uh the only other normal move i would
say is probably like c3 but um i like
developing the bishop where where should
we put this guy
where does he belong
p2's normal what kind of passive you
could go maybe
e5 you could go to e2 you could go to b5
and
uh of course what's what's the third
square
we go to d3 so how are we going to
decide between these three squares for a
bishop uh what what's going to
influence your decision there
well it feels like it does have a
great future at d5 maybe
you can you don't really want to catch
your visual
yeah i tend to agree you know bishops
are long range pieces and if you bring
them out too far in the opening uh
oftentimes they sort of get harassed so
if we we did land on b5 probably a move
like a6 at some point is going to be
awkward for us to meet um right of
course we're not going to get our bishop
trapped with like bishop a4 b5 c4
um but then at that point you know what
are we doing on b5 and like you said
probably white's not super interested in
in trading it off for this knight maybe
you can but uh probably that's not not
plan a so then d3 or b or sorry e2 or d3
which of these squares looks looks best
like e3 maybe or d3 maybe invites
c4
yeah
so this is something i wanted to point
out so d3 looks you know optically like
the better square right it's the more
active square for the bishop there's a
great open diagonal to be on but you do
have to be ready to meet moves like c4
uh when after c4 i guess you would just
have to retreat to e2 so can we improve
our position somehow
so that bishop d3 the c4 move isn't
actually really going to be a problem
how could we improve our position to
make this idea work
uh so b3 would be one way but keep in
mind what i said about uh having this
bishop outside the pawn shape it's great
to have this nice active bishop here but
it is going to make our dark squares
weak on the queen side so i'm really
wary of playing a move like b3 when
someday later on you know maybe this
will get taken and then all of these
squares are going to be holes for our
opponent
c4
e4
it's a little bit too much i think all
your pawns hang right
um so what about this move c3 this was
the idea of sort of fishing for so how
did c3 help us with our plan to play
bishop d3
yeah it opens up the c2 square so if we
get pushed away we can drop our bishop
back along this diagonal which i think
is just a little bit more comfortable
right we want to be on this long open
diagonal
so i think i like to move c3 the best
here it also has the benefit of
uh shoring up our center and after
something like queen b6 you know uh
we are sort of preemptively
prophylactically defending our pawn on
d4 so let's go with that one to start
with
back to julian
he takes how do we want to take back
so many options here
and hello ben i think i see that's been
hard to see through the lights
to um the pawn structure a little bit so
yeah
so what i would say is if we take with
the c pawn we get that symmetrical
structure
um that you would get from like an
exchange slav or something and we do
have one benefit in that structure over
our opponent our bishop is outside the
pawn chain so you might be able to argue
that white could could have some
advantage there but i'm going to say
that at the same time this knight on c6
is better than our knight on d2 right if
we were to go for that structure we
would want to develop our knight out to
the most active square on the queen's
side
um so now
knight takes obviously doesn't make any
sense it almost loses a piece even
not quite because e5 doesn't work
tactically but of course you want to
keep a pawn in the center you want to
keep your central space
so because you know i think maybe this
knight on c6 is better than this knight
on d2 i think we should take with the e
pawn to have this uh carl's badge
structure as it's not
and here the point is just that's uh
you know we're not playing uh
symmetrically anymore okay so knight h5
obviously attacks our bishop what to do
what to do with this guy
just to highlight the options
go to e5 g5 g3 e3
all four seem
like moves worth considering
maybe e5
just expect
okay
so here yeah of course you want to be
thinking about uh what's your opponent's
response going to be so bishop e5 and g5
look sort of like the most attractive
because they are
you know advancing your piece rather
than retreating
but what is black's response going to be
in in either case
yeah he might he might even try the
smooth f6 uh i'm not certain that that
is actually his idea uh
but the smooth f6 might actually look
somewhat interesting uh although it does
sort of abandon this knight here on on
h5 so
maybe let's try and calculate a little
bit let's say bishop g5 f6
some way we can take advantage of this
knight maybe go
bishop h4
and i i think our bishop looks fine over
there right what would be wrong wrong
with this i'm not so sure
so we could also go to e3 of course e3
would be the quote-unquote safe square
but you always want to be careful when
you put your bishop on a square where it
has no retreating moves uh because if it
gets attacked by a pawn then oftentimes
it's just going to be trapped
so bishop e3 for example like i i it's
just not so comfortable to have the
bishop back here it's sort of stunted by
our own pawns i think i would much
rather advance the piece
um
so we're gonna do that i'm gonna take
the wheel on this one
okay so bishop g5 i think makes the most
sense
f6 so we saw this coming now we can go
back to h4 or e3 and on this one i'm
going to let you guys decide
i'll let you decide no hints on this one
yeah g5 would be uh would be a bit much
so
i like this move h4 and again
um i think it's better than e3 for the
reasons that i sort of stated it keeps
the bishop a bit more active and you
know it leaves us with with some
retreating moves as well
okay he comes with bishop d6
so finally i don't think black made a
threat so since black doesn't have a
threat uh what what do we want to be
doing
yeah i think it's time to finish our
development here um so we would want to
play something like bishop d3 right
um but maybe black actually has a good
move in in response to this what do we
need to be uh sort of afraid of here
i think black does have a good response
yep
so you're noticing that okay so why
can't we play normally with bishop d3
well knight f4 is the big problem
attacking our pawn and our bishop so
developing this bishop actually
not going to be possible right now so
you're looking for ways to deal with
that problem which is good but so 95 was
your first guess
so that's a very forcing move so let's
go ahead and try to calculate what
happens after 9.95
yeah knight f4 anyways
and then it's back back to us we've sort
of put our knight in a precarious
position
uh of course pawn takes not possible
yeah okay so calculating here 95 knight
f4 we're thinking maybe knight d3 uh
repositioning the knight challenging
black's knight on on f4
um
and then how how do you think the line
might continue
useful to go a bit further on this one i
think
i thought maybe
yeah so i i agree that if black
exchanges there then this line would
actually be pretty nice for white
because we get our bishop out to d3 with
no problems but what if black goes back
to to g6
yeah bishop g3
and then how do you feel about that
resulting position i think we can kind
of stop calculating at that point we've
played all the forcing moves but what
what's going on in in the position after
bishop g3 are we happy we're unhappy
well our uh [ __ ] prevents such a death
one symbol maybe
yeah that that's that's the point i'm
trying to make right our goal is to
develop this bishop and so right now we
have a problem knight f4 so 95 was a
good first move to calculate because
it's very forcing so you say what
happens after 95 okay knight f4 knight
d3 can challenge that knight uh but then
knight g6 bishop g3 and i'm not really
sure how i'm you know developing my
pieces maybe black uh as someone in
chad's pointing out could even go e5
uh very actively let's get the plan
rolling so how else can we try to solve
our problem here on the f4 square
what else can we do
yeah it looks looks tough so i think
there's a couple options here obviously
we don't want to play g3 because that
again would sort of trap our own bishop
um maybe not immediately but but in the
future that's going to be a big problem
um we could think about dropping the
bishop back to g3 but then i think maybe
knight f4 anyways it's going to make it
look a little bit awkward
so maybe there's there's another way to
finish development right so we discarded
this move bishop b5 earlier but what
happens after bishop b5 uh now
bishop b5 has a pretty big advantage
here that's um
over bishop d3 and bishop e2
so what what is that
b6 and no worries
uh maybe yeah so we we do need a
response to queen b6
uh so what what could we do are our
bishops attacked
what could be going on there
obviously if we play bishop a4 um what
what was the the big concern
yeah uh queen b2 is the concern and then
maybe we're actually not getting counter
play right you know root b1 doesn't seem
to do much all our pawns are kind of
falling
so bishop e5 queen b6 we we would need a
good response to this move
but i think we do have
um
at least a very reasonable reply
yeah so a4 is okay but you're sort of
only delaying the issue right
a6 is going to come and then your b pawn
is still still in danger
so i think we have a move that defends
both the bishop and the b pawn that
could be could be helpful
yeah i think just queen b3 there is fine
then if a6
uh what can we do
so we're saying bishop b5 and b6 could
be three
a6
maybe we didn't give ourselves enough
time here we might have to pick up the
pace
yeah i think bishop a4 is is probably
fine to be honest i think that's that's
totally fine um nothing's hanging if we
get our queen captured we can take back
with the bishop
knight f4 uh we can castle i think we're
keeping it all together
so i think bishop b5 is the move that
solves our problems the best
in this position
um
but just to show you that's kind of the
thought process we want to follow here
you know what what do we want to do we
want to develop our bishop what's the
problem what does our opponent want oh
this knight f4 idea and then you go down
you evaluate your options you say okay
why is this a move better than this move
how can i solve these problems and
that's how we arrive at our move here
are we going to lose on time i might be
able to convince julian to give us more
time but we don't want to run over the
full hour that's that's for sure
and julian is thinking for the first
time here
so aside from queen v6 you know black of
course can just play a normal move black
could could castle
black could um
block a castle that would be the normal
thing to do
not sure what other normal moves there
would be
uh of course
yeah oh so a6 i didn't mention this line
but what do you think our reply would be
against that move
yeah we would want to come back this way
because again these squares
have a problem um so castles uh of
course what do we want to do here
yeah we want to finish our development
our opponent hasn't given us a reason
not to so we'll just cast
95 stuff uh yeah um the thing about this
95 move is you're correctly highlighting
that we we can play this move
uh because of the the pin but not sure
the knight does enough on that square to
be honest okay so knight f4 has been
played anyways
so now we
are sort of uh finishing up our
development and we have to decide on on
what our plan is going to be for
for the game here black has sort of
announced his intention with this move
f6 black is probably playing for this
movie e5 at some moment so now we need
to figure out where we want to put our
pieces and how we want to organize
so the last thing to do i think is find
spots for
our queen and our rooks but at the same
time you know of course we want to keep
an eye on what our opponent is doing and
probably you know find a safer home for
our bishop on h4 that looks a little bit
uh out of place
so those things in mind what what moves
are coming to mind here let's come up
with some candidates
yeah rookie one very very natural move
uh targets the e pawn helps prevent e5
what else do we have
also
i thought yeah queen c2 looks very
natural
any other ideas
yeah bishop g3 i i think these are
probably three of the best moves here
so one thing i want to point out is like
the these pieces are sort of vulnerable
right now so the one thing i don't like
about queen c2 is maybe after a6 we
don't have the most comfortable places
to put our bishop on b5 right we don't
want to come back to d3 or e2 because of
this knight
and if we come back to a4 well then
maybe our bishop actually wants the c2
square and our queen is misplaced so
for those reasons i don't think queen c2
is is quite right here
um
that being said i think both rookie 1
and bishop g3 are very good moves
um but with this point of this bishop on
b5 i do think it's better to play rookie
one here because now against a6 we can
always just slide this bishop all the
way back to f1 uh where it will be sort
of safe and sound and once we are sort
of ready for it later in the game we can
bring it out very effectively
so rookie one i think is the way to go
uh but we're not forgetting about those
other ideas we just talked about i think
bishop g3 queen c2 all very reasonable
moves uh in the near future
we also probably want to do something
with our knights uh from d2 as well this
piece
does not make the uh
the most
uh
the biggest impression on the position
okay queen b6 so
we can remember what was our intended
reply going to be to this
yeah queen b3 so what what might our
opponent have up his sleeve against
queen b3 now
right knight a5 because the king's no
longer on on e8s
so
i guess we need to figure out what's
going on there
so queen b3 knight a5 is the only new
problem really so how could we
potentially deal with that
before maybe
queen a4 yep so that keeps our bishop
defended then maybe a6
yeah bishop d7 and it's starting to look
a little bit scary for black just a
little bit scary maybe
he just does it anyways though maybe he
just takes on b2
and what
on earth is happening there
well actually i guess we win a piece we
can take c8 and take this knight on a5
right
okay so it looks like the tactics might
work out in our favor here but uh
important to notice our opponent's new
new ideas ah and julian is giving us
more time this is good
okay
we were gonna need it so i like this
move queen b3 any other suggestions
before we make the move any other ideas
yeah
talk to find one here because if we just
retreat i think black can and will uh
take our b-pawn think this time it
matters so we'll go queen b3
so now we mentioned this net a5 idea we
also mentioned this a6 idea
um if just a6 first then i think we can
just retreat our bishop if the queens
get traded we're not so unhappy here
and we can continue just slowly
improving our pieces
now now that julian's giving us time
he's taking some time
if he
gets low on the clock i will not be so
generous
uh bishop d7
okay so uh this move sort of passes
the uh the buck back to us here we can
kind of again do anything we want
so we found a nice square for our rook
we activated our queen uh what's left on
our to-do list in the early middle game
how else what other pieces do we need to
to improve
others
so maybe we're not going to have any
published positional knights
yeah so this rook on a1 isn't doing the
most this bishop on h4 also seems sort
of oddly placed you know it was nice
when this bishop was pinning the f pawn
to the queen it's not even doing that
anymore so maybe we want to get this
piece in the game or this piece in the
game and lastly our bishop is just a
little bit loose on b5 i would say and
even you know on top of that we also
have this knight on d2 which is not
leaving a stunning impression right just
sort of a passive piece
so of these four pieces which one do we
want to tackle first uh which one do we
have the clearest idea for
all right
yeah this bishop on h4 right you know
i'm not totally certain where i want
this rook uh from a1 to go maybe you
know a file will open somewhere and i'll
need it on the c file maybe i'll want to
double on the e file
uh maybe i want it on a1 maybe if queen
takes b3 ab3 gets played my rook will be
good here so i don't know where this
piece should go
uh i also don't see a super clean path
uh to improve this knight from d2 yet
right we can bring it to f1 and try to
come this way or this way but it seems a
little bit odd
and lastly um i guess we could drop this
bishop back to f1 but i mean maybe our
knight wants that square as well um so
of the four pieces i agree i think
improving this bishop with bishop g3 is
the easiest idea to play
um and that's a i think a good method of
finding ways to improve your pieces you
know sometimes you don't know where
pieces belong yet and so you want to
save those pieces for later work on
improving the pieces that uh you do have
clear ideas for
ah i blundered a tactic well i was
talking about all these uh
important things we're gonna offer a
take back
all right
see
you guys are supposed to catch me on the
tactics uh so
i said bishop d7 didn't make any threats
uh but i was wrong knight a5 of course
now attacks her queen and our bishop so
remember that bishop f1 move that i was
talking about maybe it's necessary here
maybe it is necessary
so all right we got a second life from
julian got a second life from julian
i just really thought he was developing
his pieces missed his idea
so you could trade this bishop for the
night but oftentimes the the bishops
tend to be a little bit more powerful
than and than the knights and positions
like these um and his legs for bishop
especially is a really strong piece for
white uh if you picture this bishop ever
getting out to d3 you can see it
controls huge swaths of the board
meanwhile this knight on c6 sort of
hampered by by white's pawn structure
right not a lot of advancing moves for
this thing so i think our bishop's a
better piece
um okay so takes we now have two options
so which one uh appeals to you guys
and the knight prince's position but the
aid on also
right so so that's the dilemma do we
want to bring our knight to b3 and i
don't know maybe look at a square like
c5 or do we want to change our structure
here do we want to take with the a pawn
uh giving ourselves i guess double pawns
but opening up this rook along the a5
so maybe we can take a vote who thinks
uh knight takes
two votes for knight takes
three votes for knight takes a tentative
third and i guess that leaves you two
are in favor of politics
all right not sure not sure
uh
the chat room does seem to favor pawn
takes so i do think we should take with
the pawn here in general um you know
you're told not to double your pawns but
opening up this rook is going to be
really really nice
and with knight takes
uh i don't think we're ever actually
landing on this c5 square it's hard for
white to control the square enough times
now i do think that this improves the
knight and maybe we do have a path
forward through c1 to d3 with this idea
that that kind of got brought up earlier
but
i think pawn takes here is definitely
gonna be gonna be the way to go
uh on top of that we're also gonna be
able to
maybe play a move like b4 someday and
bring our knight out so
it looks like julian was aware of our
potential idea to play this move b4
and immediately uh lashed out with a5
stopping that in its tracks
so okay this time for sure
julian has given us sort of a free move
to do whatever we want so how do we want
to improve our pieces
i'm on board with that we'll improve our
bishop here to g3
nice and simple
okay g5
black is really coming for us
so this last move is was pretty volatile
right whenever you see a big change in
the in the structure like this uh you
should always sort of take a moment to
evaluate uh what kind of options that
gives you what what this changes in the
position
so with this pawn on g5
what sort of ideas are coming to mind
now
i might want h5h4
yeah black might want to try to trap a
bishop something like h5h4
we're getting even more time all the
generosity
uh any ideas for white that come to mind
now that this pawn's out there on g5
yeah our night might get a little bit
stuck on h4
okay so h3 uh stopping g4 and giving you
know i guess both of our pieces the h2
square could make some sense
um there's one more idea i want to
highlight with
this pawn out here on g5
so whenever they
push a pawn sort of in front of their
king like this sometimes it creates
um a hook
so g5 i think is kind of a hook what
what's the you know traditional way to
latch onto that hook
i'm not saying it's the best move but
it's a move worth
considering yeah h4 is a move you always
want to consider whenever you see a move
like g5 whenever they're uh pushing upon
especially two squares like this in
front of their king you want to look at
you know putting the pawns in tension uh
giving yourself the option to open
things up
so
h3 i think is a fine move and there's
not much to calculate there right just
just a normal looking move
um h4 i guess we should probably
calculate a little bit so what how how
would play potentially continue after h4
because we are making a threat to take
on g5 twice and went upon
g4 there yeah so h4 g4
um attacks our knight our knight
actually only has one square on h2 um
but now that in turn attacks the pawn on
g4 so the line sort of continues what
might black play
yeah black might play h5 and and then
the question is uh how do we feel about
our knight on h2 is this actually going
to be
a reasonable piece for us or not
um and i think you guys are right the
answer probably is is no we we don't
like our knight here maybe one day it
gets back into the game through f1 but
that doesn't look so fun so i think i do
like this h3 move i think this is a good
way to play
and the chat is losing faith in our
position
they say our position is a mess it's
tough to find peace coordination well
that's what we're working on here we're
working on improving our pieces
yes
yeah so we've played a lot of moves to
to sort of secure a position get our
pieces on squares that make sense so now
it is useful to look for changes in
structure so you mentioned this move c4
um so that comes with the upside of
challenging black center of course
what's the downside to this
yeah b4 becomes a big hole and we're
losing um control over uh
sort of our double pawns they're
becoming sort of true weaknesses
so now i'd like to point out this knight
on d2 i think i've finally found a
reasonable plan for this night so where
where can we go with this guy how could
we possibly improve this piece
yeah i think that b1 to a3 is actually a
very reasonable path we can then land on
the b5 square which our opponent has
made some weaknesses on uh our bishop on
f1 by the way still coming in kind of
handy targeting
the b5 square as well so i like that
we'll go knight b1
so on every turn here we're just
thinking you know what can we do to to
improve our position how can we improve
our pieces
now julian on the other hand is clearly
gaining some space on the king's side
maybe he'll actually continue with
something like f5 g4
uh he did just play h6 so i think it'd
be a little bit weird to see the move h5
um
and other than that you know he still
has these ideas of potentially pushing
in the center with e5 that we need to be
aware of
uh
and
i i think that sort of does it for the
black's plans here i think e5 is this
big idea that uh
julian is relying on
and there it is e5 so how are we meeting
this this is black's big break
what can we do
what can we do
there's really only two options right
either we take or we ignore it
so what do you guys think this we have
to take because
you don't like e takes d4 so you want to
capture okay
any other thoughts
no okay so what if i told you that there
might be a
tactical resource here for white after
ed4 so
if we we don't take then you know what
is the next step in our our plant that
we were doing
right yeah knight a3 right this is what
we sort of wanted then after takes maybe
we have a little bit of a tactic there
i'm not 100 certain it works
but
uh okay rook to d1 so if we bring the
a-rook actually then then i think takes
starts to get really bad for us because
our pawn is overworked right defending
our knight in our other pawn
i think maybe we have this move knight
b5 hitting the bishop and and the pawn
on d4
so i i thought this line was worth
looking at so we hit both of these
pieces uh black if they want to defend
their pawn would go to c5 they just
retreat and i think just knight takes
knight takes knight takes totally fine
for us
so knight a3
takes here bishop c5
and then we can take and now if black
wants to sort of mess up our structure
it comes at a pretty big cost of the
dark squared bishop which is a pretty
big piece for black to be missing here
so that i'm going to say is an option
for us if we so desire
now that being said what is the downside
to taking
on e5
if there is one
coming down yeah
it opens up this nasty looking rook on
the f file and i'm gonna be honest with
you guys that's actually sort of
terrifying i think we're gonna get into
a lot of trouble if we open up that rook
i think knight h3 tactics are already
going to be in the position and you have
to be very very careful
um
so what do you think knight a3 or d
takes e
yeah i sort of sort of led you on this
one i like knight a3 to be honest though
it looks very complicated dxe might
might very well be the better move
i'll leave it up to you guys here
one vote for knight a3 any dissenters
okay pawn takes
all right
any
tiebreakers
all right well then i'm breaking the tie
uh we'll play that a3 this time
so now what can black do you know black
of course can still go after uh this e
takes d sort of line you can also try to
push e4 maybe e3 later uh and with rook
to e8 maybe that's what he's he's
hinting at
um
so now we have two options i guess we
can bring our knight to b5 hitting this
bishop we can come back to c2 trying to
take a more defensive posture defend our
d pawn maybe come out with knight e3
those sorts of ideas
what do you guys think
yeah all right we'll go to b5 we'll be
active be active
hey goes all the way back
and what's our follow-up what can we do
um
i'm worried about it i'm going to
be
free
i don't know now we've got that covered
we've got that covered
so i think it's time to to start
calculating here um
lots of tactical ideas in the position
so the downside of gtx that i mentioned
is that after pawn takes it opens up
this rook on the f file there is
actually also a very big upside to
taking on e5 so so what is that
what is that upside
how would that benefit us
this exchange of pawns
yeah so just like you know how f takes
opens up the file for black d takes
opens up the d file for for white so it
gives us access to this d pawn
so i'm thinking you know maybe we can
bring a rook to d1 try and prepare this
we could also just capture right away uh
but if we capture right away after takes
takes you have to be thinking about uh
these moves like knight takes h3 you
have to be ready to respond to them yeah
i was thinking maybe they could do that
for them and play anything it's true if
they have a roof on p1 already
yeah okay so you're thinking takes takes
rook d1 knight h3 king h2
um
we're actually still not threatening to
capture this knight
um but we are on on the d pawn so i mean
how might play continue there
looks complicated right looks very very
complicated
yeah to be honest um i'm not so sure no
yes
after that
okay
uh so knight f2 bishop f2 and you're
saying um
you're saying e4 is check maybe is the
problem
yeah yeah e4 is is check right yeah um
so yeah could could cause us some
problems
so if we do take
take maybe we do have to deal with
knight h3 somehow
maybe we do have to deal with knight h3
so what are our options to deal with
that so maybe we can defend our knight
or maybe we can
move our knight
of course but it's a bit of an
artificial perhaps i mean king h2 i
actually don't think solves our problem
i think knight takes h3 is still in the
position even though even if it's not
check
so i'm thinking maybe we go something
like rookie 3 and just defend this
knight um either we can do that right
away or we can take first
now my concern is if we don't take black
might go for this idea of e4 and so we
have to be
uh at least willing to to play that
position as well which
could be tough
so i am a little bit scared of this e4
idea so i think we we do need to capture
this guy so anybody against capturing
all right
by default maybe yeah so i there were
other options you could go rd1 you could
go rookie 3 you could keep it a bit more
closed but i think it is time i think
you guys are right
when it's time it's time
we could also just snag this night off
the board that's exactly right um so how
how does that look uh bishop takes
knight how would black reply
this game started
yeah it's starting to look a little bit
weak
take with the e pawn you think
um
i actually think that black's position
really revolves around this e4 idea uh
he wants to sort of break through in the
center like that get those pawns rolling
so in this case i think the adage
captured towards the center remains true
i think black wants to take with the g
pawn take towards the center and then
again i think these ideas are e4 and f3
to follow are gonna be a little bit
frightening for white to deal with so
i'm not super in favor of actually
capturing this knight
now what about this move rook to d1
what was our well we had a problem with
it though what was the problem
now it takes h3 uh however we didn't
calculate maybe the most obvious move
but what happens if we take take the
knight
yep so black gets the piece back on on
f3
and then do we have any good follow-ups
there
yes if we take the ball on d5 there and
he has basically e6
bishop where
bishop b6
yeah sure
maybe
um instead of vertex
yeah we could go bishop g2 hitting this
rook
and then maybe actually we do have
bishop takes d5 with check there that
looks kind of interesting
um
so i think i actually like this line for
us i think that's the best we're gonna
get here i think we we get into trouble
so why don't we we give it a go give it
a go here go one
and we only have about 10 minutes left
in the class so we got to go fast
gotta go fast now
that's okay this has been a good
exercise so far i think
c4
yeah so c4 i think um runs into a
problem where black can sort of sidestep
us and get those pawns rolling again
like black splat's ideas are to sort of
come down the board to come after us
so bishop e6 is simple enough just
defending the pawn
um so how can we improve
i'm asking myself just as much as you
how can we improve
uh maybe if we had to pick a worst piece
here it's knight on v5 is very active
but it doesn't really contribute to the
attack on the center
uh our bishop also of course leaves
something to be desired
uh so maybe we can just shore up our
position to move like king h2
what do you guys think any other ideas
well moving this pawn is always going to
be really scary because black has a lot
of attackers on h3 here
you're exactly right so now knight h3 is
a threat again i i don't know how i
already forgot this um but maybe it's
not such a big deal again right takes
takes rook f3 uh bishop g2 and if the
rook moves again we can take on d5
and if the rook doesn't move we can win
an exchange which
might not be the most impressive thing
of all time but
it is an exchange
so i think i do like this move king king
to g2 and then maybe we can work on
rerouting this knight somewhere else
actually i'm not sure where
i think a good alternative might be
knight to h2 trying to do something
similar
um
and other than that i'm really not
seeing a lot of a lot of moves here
so let's let's take a pic do we want to
go knight h2 heading for g4 or king h2
just trying to solidify
g4
well i i'm not so sure it's forced right
black can just defend his pawn just
leave the knight there
i like that
all right let's give it a go let's give
it a go
and the best part about knight h2 is now
it's our opponent's turn okay so h5 uh
pretty quickly
so this move kind of makes a threat
right kind of threatens h4 when we're
not so so happy about this trade still
or maybe we are
maybe we are
uh however this does take away knight g4
right
yeah we can go h4 but then we get this
g4 structure
which uh i mean i wasn't so happy with
right it makes her not an h2 look very
very silly
bishop
uh bishop e2
yeah um
i'm not so happy about so giving this
bishop up for for the night right we've
been leaving this night here it's been
it looks pretty annoying but
yeah i think i actually like that idea
ben i think this is a good one so we
provoked h5 and now this pawn on g5 is
is actually hanging so we can just bring
the knight back and attack this again i
think this is
uh i mean it's a simple way to play but
i think it's it's not a bad play to play
at all
and back to julian so how can he deal
with this pawn maybe he can play g4
and how would we want to reply to that
uh yeah we could go knight g5 um uh
first things first though we probably
don't want to allow g takes h3 so i
think we should always be capturing on
g4 unless anyone disagrees
all right let's do that
oh bishop takes okay so now he's pinning
our knights scary stuff uh however this
leaves the d-pawn behind
so we do have the option
of capturing on f4 and capturing on d5
if you guys so desire
do we desire
yeah let's do it let's go get them let's
go get them
and
maybe he missed it maybe he didn't
okay we'll follow through we'll see what
his uh his point is see what the idea
for him
was against this he might just take us
take our pawn
no he comes back
he's back with
this v6
so we're under attack
where to go
where to go with the rook
rook do you want you said
d2 are doing okay
um yeah i like d2 let's keep our options
open for doubling rooks somewhere also
you know we're anticipating bishop b3 so
we don't want to to put a rook on on
freeze
bishop d3 is deadly
yeah so fish e3 looks like a pretty nice
move however i think we have a nice
little tactical opportunity here once
again
um
to sort of rescue this knight from no
man's land over here on b5
so i mean it was it was nice on b5 it it
misplaced some of our opponent's pieces
but it's not really contributing in the
center and so i i really would like to
take any opportunity to get it back in
the game so what am i talking about what
what opportunity yeah i like knight d4
bam we hit that guy we hit that guy you
cannot take because the rook on
uh on e8 hanks
okay bishop f7 defends the rook
so now what was uh what was the point of
our nights our night adventure
we could come back but i i think we
should take i think this this must be
the most
generally
yeah um i mean your pieces are going to
be more active further in position
although sometimes they're trading moves
yeah well we came back in order to go
forward right
um
but yeah
it's tough to say that retreating moves
in general are bad it is a game of
specifics
okay now we have successfully given our
opponent four pawn islands to deal with
um so what do we want to do
what do we want to do now
yeah we could just double up here target
this guy
um
let's try to anticipate what our
opponent would do in in reply
yeah maybe bishop c4 hitting us we would
go rookie three
uh actually that that looks pretty good
for us that that line specifically
yeah
yeah we've got some nice threats there
um so
i think after rookie two uh
black might just play this move um pawn
to e4
and then again we have to decide what's
going on and go knight g5 but then maybe
bishop
g6 is good enough to defense
and
then actually the line kind of continues
we have like f3 ideas there's bishop a7
with e3 to come
looks complicated
rick d7 that looks like a
very good normal move i have no problems
with work today so
um i think we have a lot of options this
move knight g5 also stuck out to me just
to try to reroute this knight uh in
front of this pawn
but i think i like your move rook
descent and since it is supposed to be
the class playing julian and not me
we'll we'll go with that one
okay and only three minutes left so
both in the class and on our clock
maybe should be six
brooks attacked we kind of want to stay
on the seventh so let's go to b7
and now i might just have to start
taking over a little bit
because we are
dangerously close to being totally out
of time
uh
still targeting this guy keeping the
rook active and we're hitting the e5
pawn as well
uh i do think that you guys are on the
right track with stuff like bishop d3 i
think we need to activate this guy
and d3 looks like a great way to do it
makes that piece work in combination
with our rook
again this move knight g5 is sticking
out to me as well
okay
our guy is attacked so i could go to g5
i'm actually going to come back to d2
instead though
uh the reason being
it looks safer
c5 makes a threat thankfully i missed
i did notice this time so i'm going to
move my rook away from the thread of
capture
looks very good hard to keep track of
four pawn islands i would say very
difficult for black
okay
i will take
and if i take this guy i think the idea
was bishop b6
um i can take here he can take here i
move i get checkmated that doesn't sound
like fun so i'm not going to do
that not gonna do that one this time
nearly got me
nearly got me
a bishop back to d5 i think it's time to
harass this rick a little bit this works
been in my face for far too long
i'll make it move again
hitting again another weak pawn
and let's kill our opponent's bishop's
pair
this should pair far too strong so we'll
take rid of we'll get rid of that
and we'll bring this knight to e4 oh
what a beautiful piece what a beautiful
piece
and resigns we did it we beat the master
we beat julian
so i am running out of time here but
let's quick quickly do a computer
analysis see if either of us missed
anything ridiculous
looks like we were getting outplayed for
most of this game and at some point it
took a turn
so
uh i'm not sure what the theory says on
these kinds of things looks like this is
a line maybe not a very good line ah i
was totally wrong bishop e3 is the best
move here so i was a little bit wary
about bringing the bishop back to a weak
square but we came out to g5 and this
has also been played
now bishop b5 and black is a little bit
better because of the big center it
looks like everything we did made a lot
of sense um
let's see what the computer thought
about this this decision
let's see what it thought i thought it
doesn't matter both moves very good
um although it does like knight b3 a bit
better so i guess you guys you guys were
right oh
no they're back to being the same all
right about the same
and a5 i thought made sense by julian i
like this h3 move by you guys and then
uh knight b1 i think this was a nice
maneuver and it didn't change the
evaluation so it seems like we're on the
right track and then you have someone in
the chat thought that e5 is a little bit
premature seems like the computer agrees
and actually here the computer is
suggesting that potentially we can take
or actually go c4 so maybe our plan with
knight a3 was a little bit too slow
maybe we did need to act in the center
and then just quickly going through here
de5 is the best move you guys are too
smart
uh and then d e f e r d1 this should be
six
knight h2 was not so good
uh turns out we do need to go c4 as
someone mentioned i was worried about
this move d4 but maybe we can get some
kind of blockade going
said knight h2 and knight h5 was the way
to punish us just hitting our bishop
instead though after h5 we can come back
and then things are not at all bad for
us after bishop takes now we just sort
of take over
yeah this move knight d4 was kind of
nice apparently 96 is a lot better but
by this point we were moving pretty
quickly
and here the bishop's pair was supposed
to be enough for equality but we started
targeting all those pawns and then it
got very very difficult for for black
and then wow knight e4 hitting
everything
so sad or for black
so thanks to uh julian for playing and
also giving us like an hour of extra
time and a take back
uh the take back helps uh we missed a
pretty simple tactic early on but we did
manage to come back and i think we
played a really nice interesting game
here where black was trying to push
through the center we kept fighting to
improve our pieces to challenge him in
the center hopefully you guys liked this
sort of uh format for a class i don't
think i'm going to do this often but i
do think it could be fun to bring this
in every once in a while uh play a game
together talk about all the ideas and
see it through start to finish uh so if
you guys have time please do stick
around our grand master in residence
romaine edward is coming in right after
me and he'll be talking talking some
more chess
as always my name is caleb denby this
has been the road to 2000 and i'll see
you guys next time